جددت فرنسا تمسكها برفض قرار قاده
الانقلاب في النيجر طرد سفيرها فينيانو
واكدت ان قراراتها تجاه النيجر ستكون
مبنيه على المباحثات مع الرئيس محمد بازو
كان هذا خبر حلقتنا ولنا في نقاشه ثلاثه
مسارات ما هي خيارات باريس للتعامل مع
تفاعلات ازمه سفرها في النيامي ما هي
الرسائل التي يبعثها اعلان قاده الانقلاب
الاستعداد لمواجهه ما يسمونه بالغزو ما هي
المسارات المحتمله للازمه النيجيريه على
ضوء هذه التعقيدات
من حضور افريقيا اعتقد انها مساله وقت قبل
ان يكون على فرنسا ان تستسلم الفحل القول
ان
تقدم مكروم بتصريح مفاده انه على اتصال
مستمر مع الرئيس منقلب عليه بازوم يعطي
الانطباع للشعب النيجر ان بازومي لطالما
كان دميه فرنسا قالت فرنسا انها لا تعترف
بالقلابيين العسكريين ولكن في نهايه
المطاف هؤلاء العسكريون هم الذين يحضرون
على ما يبدو بدعم شعب النيجر اذا كانت
الحكومه الانتقاليه التي اسستها القياده
الانقلابيه العسكريه قد اعتبرت ان بازون
لم يعد الرئيس وانه على فرنسا ان تغادر
بقواتها اعتقد ان فرنسا تحاول تاخير
العمليه وتكسب لكي تكسب الوقت ولكن هذا
يزيد الوضع سوءا
الانقلاب في النيجر يقوم على التخلص من
الوجود ما يسميه باستعمار الفرنسي فرنسا
لم تعد عليها ادوات كثيره كما يتعلق
بالموقف من النيجر الرئيس الازمه الحاليه
عدم قبول فرنسا بالوضع الجديد في ظل وجود
علاقات طيبه وقويه مع الرئيس المقلب علي
محمد
على ما يبدو وهم فرنسي بالبقاء في افريقيا
انا اعتقد تعيش في مرحله ما قبل الانقلاب
واعتقد عليها اعتقد هناك وضع جديد توقف
الامريكي موقف لحد بعيده التابع مقاربه
حذره تقوم على الحاله الدبلوماسي على
الحوار وتستبعد شكله باخر الخيار العسكري
وهذا ايضا يعقد موقف فرنسي خاصه لدول عدم
وجود دعم الامريكي لاي تحرك عسكري على
الارض من قبل
هذه الامور مجتمعه تعقد الرؤيه الفرنسيه
والتخلص الفرنسي من ارث الماضي من جهه وفي
نفس الوقت
تجعل الدعايه الروسيه في افريقيا قابله
للتصديق في اوساط تعادي فرنسا عاطفيه
لاسباب تاريخيه مبرده التحدي على الاداره
الفرنسيه الان هو كيف يمكن ان توفق بين
هيبه دوله مثل فرنسا يفترض ان يكون
لموقفها تاثيرات ميدانيه وفي نفس الوقت
القبول بان المجتمعات الافريقيه تتغير
وبانه لا يكفي لفهم ما يجري لو مفاجنر
والمرتزقه الروس والدعايه الروسيه هناك
ضروره للقول بان مكانها يجري في السابق لم
يعد ممكنا في العلاقه الفرنسيه الافريقيه
وفي نفس الوقت لا يمكن نفي ان موسكو بشكل
اساسي وربما بكين احيانا تستفيد وتحرض من
اجل انهاء الحضور الفرنسي المباشر
العسكريون في النيجر قد اوضحوا الموضوع
قالوا انهم مستعدون
لاي محاوله تدخل عسكري هذه الرساله موجهه
مباشره لدول الاعضاء في الاكواس ايضا
رساله لفرنسا بان هؤلاء الانقيلابيين
لديهم دعم من الشعب في النيجر ولكن هذا
الرساله ايضا هي موجهه الى الشعب نفسه
داخل النيجر ان هذه لحظه بقاء واستمراريه
وان الانسلابيه العسكريين يقاتلون حربا ضد
القمع والاستعمار الفرنسي هل يمكن استخدام
الشعب كورقه للتخلص من الوجود الفرنسي هذا
بالتحديد التكتيك الذي يستخدمه الانبيون
العسكريون من خلال
ايضا استخدام الشعب الذي يتظاهر امام
السفاره الفرنسيه والقواعد الفرنسيه
العسكريه كذلك يجب الحذر من عدم حصول اي
هجم ات ضد هذه المصالح الفرنسيه
اعتقد احد الاخطاء الاستراتيجيه لاكويس
لانها لو واحد من خلال العسكري مبكرا جدا
انا اعتقد لانه كويس لديها ادوات محدوده
جدا اولا هناك حاله الانقسام داخل الاقواس
بنتكلم على الاقل حتى هذه اللحظه ثلاث دول
خارج مساله دعم من اي تدخل عسكري بيتكلم
على مالي بوركينا فاسو طبعا والنيجر الامر
الثاني متعلق بالقوات العسكريه لاكواس
اقواس ليست منظمه مثلا مثل حلف شمال
الاطلس الامر الثالث متعلق بانه يعني
ادوات الاقتصاديه والسياسيه قد تكون اكثر
جدوى